foreign
the life I've had in Hollywood and all
over the world to come back in one piece
it's pretty much a miracle now I feel
like myself again you say right off the
top of the show that you know when it
comes to your life you've had an
interesting journey and that you're
surprised after 20 years that you've
come back to Canada back to your
family's property what is the most
special thing about this property for
you it was always My Sanctuary it was
always my Saving Grace I knew that if I
kept this place I could keep one foot on
Vancouver Island I could kind of handle
anything out there which I did you know
I had quite a wild little experience and
you know it's not over yet but at least
I have here to keep me grounded my
grandmother offered this property to me
so I bought it and then I didn't come in
for 25 years it's really easy to kind of
get swept up in that world and and keep
your feet on the ground somehow and I
don't know if I'm really known for being
a very grounded person but when I'm here
I'm just yeah I'm just me I go right
back to my childhood I I'm still a girl
that you know runs around Barefoot and
gets in trouble and mischievous and you
know talking to the trees and the
Animals looking for fairies in my garden
you know just it's the same space I
thought it'd be great to create a clean
palette
now with this whole team I definitely
want to take it to the next level three
buildings six acres an endless project
just being here and putting around and
and kind of realizing the
the potential of the place and that I
could really do something special
there's 12 more buildings to build than
barns there's all sorts of stuff so it's
just the beginning it's not even close
to being done but every day we do a
little something to make it a little
better I'm working every day in the
garden it's crazy